décors et bâtiments reproduit à
l'identique les assemblées pièce par
pièce plus de soixante mètres de rails
au sol cette reproduction du rio grande
des southern un réseau mythique de
l'ouest américain est une oeuvre unique
son architecte le voici michel fois ci
il ya consacré plus de dix ans de sa vie
très gravement malade il confie son
monument à deux amis avec qui il a
multiplié les voyages dans le colorado
il a ramené c'est sa terre des états
unis dans des endroits particuliers pour
refaire fectivement sont toutes toute
son exploitation minière avec les bras
déjections de mine quand on venait ici
heureux faire va voir trôner les trains
sur cette merveille c'était sans égale
quoi jaillard sait
depuis plusieurs jours déjà les deux
amis procède d'un démontage méticuleux
avec son auteur ils se sont connus il ya
plus de 40 ans autour de leur passion
commune pour les trains miniatures ils
veulent sauver son installation il faut
démonter parce que sinon ça va finir ou
la déchetterie
c'est dommage
bien sûr donc vraiment récupère ça lui
fait plaisir et puis puis nous ça nous
fait aussi plaisir et ça nous permettra
de consoles
une grande partie des décors ira
enrichir les reproductions de ces
passionnés du réseau américain certaines
pièces et éléments seront envoyés aux
états unis chez d'autres collectionneurs
[Musique]